on passe désormais à la deuxième partie
de cette émission notre deuxième débat
il est consacré au contrôle dans les
ehpad vous souvenez c'était il ya six
mois la parution des fossoyeurs le livre
choc du journaliste victor keystone l
enquête choc devrais je dire jeté une
lumière crue sur les dérives des
établissements qui accueillent les
personnes âgées dans la foulée le sénat
créer une commission d'enquêté mêmes qui
crée une mission d'information sur le
contrôle des ehpad vient de rendre son
rapport la semaine dernière que
préconisent les sénateurs pour mettre
fin aux abus et pour améliorer la vie
des résidents c'est un sujet on fait le
point avec ses cimes six ans après le
scandale orpea le gouvernement s'est
engagé à mener des inspections dont les
7500 ehpad français d'ici deux ans les
sénateurs veulent aller plus loin et
propose de contrôler les sièges sociaux
des groupes un des angles morts des
contrôles dans les maisons de retraite
cela permettrait de mieux savoir comment
est dépensé l'argent public s'est aperçu
que tout était fait pour
rentabiliser l affaire est détourné cet
argent qui normalement devait rester
hors du temps et c'est là où il faut
contrôler beaucoup plus c'est là où on
s'est aperçu que en ne contrôlant que
les établissements pouvait pas vérifier
la bonne utilisation de ces fonds
publics et que au niveau du siège on ne
voyait plus ou pas c'est cet argent qui
souvent malheureusement aller plus haut
lieu des actionnaires que les autres
recommandations mieux coordonner les
contrôles car actuellement ils sont
effectués indépendamment par la rs la
répression des fraudes ou l'inspection
du travail les sénateurs proposent qu'un
comité national joue le rôle de chef
d'orchestre tous les services contrôler
les établissements mais les contrôles de
façon d'abord aléatoire pour eux et
surtout sans concertation sans
coordination et c'est dommage parce que
il est évident que lorsque dans un
établissement et les problèmes un niveau
particulier on pourrait s'interroger et
voir s'il n'y en a pas sur d'autres
plans or ce n'est pas fait parce que des
services de communiquer entre eux je
crois qu'il faut absolument à l'avenir
condé
une obligation de coordination les
auteurs du rapport sénatorial veulent
aussi limiter l'expansion des maisons de
retraite privées et laissé plus de place
au public pour éviter la
commercialisation à outrance enfin il
demande plus de moyens humains car le
manque de personnel est souvent la cause
des maltraitances les sénateurs qui
rencontrent demain le ministre des
solidarités jean-christophe combes
espère que ces mesures feront l'objet
d'une loi sur le grand âge pour le
moment elle n'est toujours pas inscrite
dans le calendrier du gouvernement
on en parle ce soir avec mes invités
michel meunier bonsoir vous êtes
sénatrice socialiste de loire-atlantique
échos rapporte heureux de cette
commission d'enquêté de cette mission
d'information sur sur le contrôle des
ehpad chaque oeil aussi eric fregona
directeur adjoint de l'association des
directeurs au service des personnes
âgées la dpa c'est ça je me suis pas
trompé et bien c'est parfait et puis
frédéric bizarre on connaît bien à sens
public vous êtes économiste spécialiste
des questions de santé et auteur de
l'autonomie solidaire en santé aux
éditions michalon depuis bien sûr emilie
l'appel ce qui reste avec moi tout au
long de cette émission on va commencer
avec vous michel meunier vous avez
anglais votre mission d'information sur
la question de contrôle sur les ehpad
pourquoi spécifiquement cette question
du contrôle pour aborder ce sujet là
notre mission est fait suite au livre de
victor les fossoyeurs et qui au travers
d'un exemples très précis montré et
démontré qu'il y avait une mauvaise
utilisation de l'argent public
dévoiement l'argent public donc on s'est
posé la question du contrôle du contrôle
ça a été vraiment notre
leitmotiv est la raison de notre rapport
c'est dans un contexte général du
secteur médico social qu'on connaît et
qu'on connaissait et on aurait pu aussi
abondé sur les difficultés et le manque
d'attractivité des professionnels mais
on ne s'est pas éloigné du sujet du
contrôle qui a été à cause des scandales
qui avait tablé à cause des abus à cause
de tout ce qu'on a pu lire comme comme
des riffs parmi ces dérives justement
sur la question des contrôles et réprime
ona il y avait sept cette idée on a eu
plusieurs exemples depuis que c'était
des contrôles un peu b parce que non
seulement il était très rare mais très
souvent les directeurs d'établissements
étaient prévenus à l'avancé une certaine
manière un peu comme un restaurateur qui
seraient prévenus à l'avancé une il y
avait tout dit de conter cccd encore le
cas aujourd'hui il y avait deux types de
contrôles il y avait des contrôles
inopinés mais qu'ils étaient trop peu
fréquents évidemment des agences
régionales de santé et des départements
et puis il y avait des contrôles qui
était prévu à l'avance donc
effectivement où tout pouvait être
organisé au préalable il ya peu de
changements aujourd'hui il ya plus de
contrôles qui ont été mis en place pour
autant l'ad-pa nous considérons que
contrôler tout le monde ne cessez de
contrer tout le monde dans une situation
comme l'a précisé madame la sénatrice où
il ya quand même une situation de crise
dans le secteur par manque de moyens
contrôler tout le monde ne va peut-être
pas dans le bon sens par contre cible et
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord pour
cible et ce pour sur lequel on a des
suspicions et organiser ce contrôle au
niveau national nous sommes pas moyen de
réguler quand même le secteur de se dire
ça peut tomber sur tout le monde on
contrôle tout le monde et pas seulement
bien sûr cette relation mais si vous
voulez lorsque votre voiture ne
fonctionne pas c'est parce qu'elle est
en panne il est dès lors qu'elle est en
panne c'est pas parce que vous allez
contrôler qu'elle est en panne ça ne
suffit pas il faut mettre en parallèle
les moyens pour pouvoir soigner le
secteur qui dit contrôler 10 des quelque
chose à contrôler autrement dit un
cahier des charges de la caisse qui doit
y avoir ce cahier des charges pour celle
de la route
d'abord je comprends que cette mission
elle était nécessaire puisque c'est le
rôle des pouvoirs publics lorsqu'il ya
une crise aussi importante qui touche
quand même l'ensemble de la population
avec autant de retentissement médiatique
la pub doit agir mais ce que j'espère
c'est que les pouvoirs publics bien
conscience qu'on est un peu sur une
mission flash d'urgence pour essayer de
colmater un peu les brèches d'un système
en totale déperdition et revenir et et
que le problème il est ailleurs que
simplement mettre plus d'argent sur le
contrôle sinon je dirais crf je crois
que ça il faut s'asseoir un diagnostic
partagé parce que c'est le cas c'est le
cas de tout le système de santé est ce
que la mission flash de monsieur de
braun bon ok pourquoi pas pour deux mois
pour passer les cours des mesures
d'urgence des mesures d'urgence bon
juste un point très structurant qu'est
la démographie et que la population
vieillit depuis 200 ans mais
particulièrement depuis 20 ans entre
2000 et 2030 on a un effet
vieillissement qui est historiquement
très important d'abord avec on va dire
un vieillissement du des 60 70 ans vous
avez une part de la population de 60 ans
qui est passée de 20% à 27% aujourd'hui
qui valait à 23% mais nous rentrons dans
le grand vieillissement c'est à dire
l'augmentation très forte de la
population des plus de 75 ans inquiets
de 2,12 millions 300 mille aujourd'hui
depardon 6 millions 300 mille et qui met
de plus de 12 millions en 2040 mon coin
c'est de dire que la question du du
coeur du grand vieillissement elle est
devant nous elle est devant nous donc
quand vous voyez l'état du système fasse
finalement une pression qui est
relativement faible et qui était
parfaitement prévisible ya 30 ans voyez
bien que si on ne prend pas urgent à man
le système dans sa globalité
je pense que dans sa globalité c'est le
système de santé oms va y avoir accès
voilà donc pour juste pour ce qu'est ce
qu'il ne contrôle encore prime de
contrôle c'est quoi c'est un problème de
gouvernance c'est un problème qu'en fait
il n'y a pas c'est comme dans toute
société quand il ya un problème où il ya
eu des dérives quelles que soient ses
dérives ses qui est un problème
institutionnel d'accord donc là on est
au coeur et c'est la mère de toutes les
réformes dans ce système de santé et pas
que dans le système de santé c'est de
remettre la gouvernance c'est-à-dire
qu'ils dirigent quoi sur pied entre qui
peut à cette table me dire le rôle de la
caisse nationale de santé autonomie de
drs et des conseils départementaux dans
le quotidien des des ehpad sur un plan
va dire de régulation justement un
personne parce que les rôles sont d'une
confusion extrême et les administrations
de quand même pas entre elles comme le
disait bernard s'était dit dans le nom
ils peuvent pas communiquer parce que
finalement on ne sait plus qui fait quoi
qui donne les autorisations dans crs
mais sait il faut passer par le conseil
départemental
mais il ya aussi la cns acquis c'est
absolument illisible et donc ça c'est
pas un travail d'une mission flush et
c'est pas c'était pas je pense le rôle
des sénateurs mais oui et ça c'est
c-zéro euros de coût mais c'est
extrêmement important pour que ça soit
lisible d'abord des familles parce que
c'est on a tous eu autour de nous des
cas de gens qui nécessitait d'aller en
en ehpad c'est juste illisible vous
n'avez aucun qui ne savent pas à qui
s'adresser on ne sait pas à qui
s'adresser alors je reviens vers vous
parce que dans dans le rapport vous
pointez notamment l'obsession des
groupes qui est d'être rentable et vous
prenez même un contrôle non pas
seulement des établissements mais des
groupes et qui les contrôle s'avère
qu'il ya tout un modèle économique à
revoir au fond tout à fait et pour
abonder ce que vient de dire
le bris beevor frédéric c'est justement
la force de ces groupes alors à but
lucratif mais aussi il faut voir les
grands groupes associatifs de peut-être
profiter du système
de nuages de choses pas du tout plaire
en ayant des structures pyramidales des
organisations régionales
el nacional et qui fait qu'au bout du
bout on ne sait plus
où se trouve le bon niveau de contrôle
que la culture de la rentabilité guide
ces groupes privés à but lucratif ce
n'est pas non plus très étonnant
écoutez il ya quelque chose de choquant
de vouloir faire de l'argent sur de la
vulnérabilité puisqu'on parle de la très
grande vulnérabilité des personnes qui
sont
pas autonomes ou très peu autonome et
donc cette recherche de rentabilité et
de faire des bénéfices sur l'argent
public qui est octroyé est quelque chose
d'insupportable qu'il faut arrêter ça
veut dire qu'il faut sortir le secteur
privé de cette activité alors on ne dit
pas ça 1 le rapport ne dit pas
supprimant toutes les ehpad privée
lucrative mais on dit qu'il faut
encadrer qu'il faut contrôler et qu'il
faut sanctionner et c'est pas des gros
mots la sanction fait partie de
l'éducation
l'argent public qui est donnée pour
avoir
un objectif d'accompagnement et
d'accueil des personnes âgées elle doit
aller là où elle est destinée c'est à
dire sur la bientraitance des personnes
âgées qui sont en résidence alors ils
rigolaient ce qu'on n'oublie pas un peu
vite une grande partie des ehpad
dépendent aussi du secteur public ou du
secteur associatif et est-ce qu'ils sont
confrontés aux mêmes problèmes qu'on a
pu voir dans les enquêtes sur le privé
les difficultés et le manque
d'accompagnement le retrouve dans tout
le secteur aussi bien associatif donc
l'associatif représentent 30% 50% pour
le public est peu ou prou 20% pour les
privés commerciaux et dans les privés
commerciaux il ya des groupes qui sont
ici qu'on aborde aujourd'hui donc il
représente peut-être 15% tout cas de
toute l'offre donc effectivement les
problèmes se retrouve partout je dirais
que on le fait on ne se pose jamais la
question finalement et nous en tant que
directeur on se rend compte lorsqu'on
parle aux administrations on a toujours
affaire à un financeur d'un côté et à
celui qui va contrôler la qualité de
l'autre et lorsqu'on dit à la personne
qui fait la qualité et qui vient nous
contrôler on leur dit mais nous on peut
pas faire cette qualité parce qu'on n'a
pas les financements
c'est pas notre problème vous devez le
faire et puis quand audio financeurs il
nous faut plus d'argent pour pour
assurer la qualité qui est demandé le
financeur nous dit je suis désolée c'est
pas voté ou plus haut niveau de l'état
et du coup je n'ai pas les moyens donc
la véritable question qui va se poser et
là je rejoins ce que disait monsieur sur
la l'évolution démographique c'est quel
virage les français je dirais plus
globalement la france souhaite apporter
quelques virages ont fait prendre donc
là il n'ya pas dix mille choix sur le
plan je dirais financiers en termes de
finances publiques il ya soit c'est le
contribuable qui va devoir payer et du
coup on fera une grande solide comme une
grande prestation autonomie digne de ce
nom en accompagnant dignement les gens
et on sent le travail de qualité soit on
va passer par des assurances soit on va
passer par le consommateur lui même
c'est à dire que le consommateur de
raffinements comme vous soyez en tout
cas il faut que ce débat il soit mis
vraiment en place et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut la loi autonomie alors revoir le
modèle économique c'est aussi revoir le
mode de financement vous l'avait dit et
pour le c'est à dire des moyens de la
collectivité accorde à cette question du
grand âge et c'était justement le but de
la fameuse cinquième branche de la
sécurité sociale qui a été créée en 2020
aurait essayé de voir ce que ça a donné
avec alexandre tout ça a donné quoi
cette loi alors pour l'instant mature on
ne peut pas dire qu'elle a vraiment
changé la donne tout simplement car il
faut du temps pour créer une nouvelle
branche de la sécurité sociale une loi
de 2020 a permis à la création de cette
branche dédiée à la lutte contre la
dépendance et finalement elle n'est
entrée en vigueur véritablement que le
mois dernier donc ça a mis du temps
notamment pour des questions de réglage
juridique alors on va rappeler l'idée de
ce projet qui est de faire de la
dépendance le cinquième risque couverts
par la sécurité sociale au même titre
que les quatre premières branches
l'assurance maladie la branche retraite
à la branche accidents du travail et la
branche famille cette 5ème branche
indépendant sales à plusieurs objectifs
couvrir la perte d'autonomie à d assurer
leurs soins médicaux et éventuellement
leur placement en hébergement
spécialisés et aider toutes les
personnes en situation de handicap ça
c'est pour les objectifs mais sk de
l'argent comment la finance 7/5 et bien
le financement c'est tout le problème
une cinquième branche qui ne part pas de
zéro qui intègre par exemple le budget
de l'ancienne caisse nationale de
solidarité pour l'autonomie également
une part du budget de l'état consacré à
ces questions de dépendance d'autonomie
pour l'instant une part de la csg la
contribution sociale généralisée
cet impôt qui est prélevé sur le revenu
des français et bien cette part de csg
affectés à cette cinquième branche de la
sécurité sociale ce qui fait et bien
pour l'instant un total d'un budget de
34 milliards d'euros pour le moment mais
ce n'est pas du tout suffisant car avec
le car avec le vieillissement de la
population et bien en 2030 les
différents rapports estiment à une
dizaine une dizaine de milliards d'euros
supplémentaires les besoins financiers
de cette lutte contre la dépendance et
maintenant la question se pose où
trouver cet argent supplémentaire pour
cette cinquième branche de la sécu est
ce qu'il faut augmenter les cotisations
salariales patronales la csg ou faut-il
créer bien une deuxième journée de
solidarité des entreprises pour
l'autonomie sur le modèle de la première
journée créée en 2004 autant de pistes
qui devaient être discutés dans une
grande loi pour l'autonomie promise par
emmanuel macron dans le premier
quinquennat à la fin de l'année 2019
mais on attend toujours cette grande loi
on a beaucoup entendu merci beaucoup à
l'exemple parler de coquilles vides à
propos de cette cinquième manche
frédéric bizarre est ce qu'ils font ça
servait à quelque chose de créer une
cinquième branche de mon point de vue
j'attends toujours un argument qui soit
un peu convaincant par rapport à ça pour
quoi il faut bien voir qu'en fait ce
qu'on a fait en 2004 c'est qu'on a c'est
paraît il y avait une caisse d'assurance
maladie qui assurait le financement en
direct de 2,7 un peu de ce nouveau
risque qui était un risque émergents
inde au début des années 2000 qui était
le risque dépendance port et puis il se
risque se développant donc on a créé
cette caisse nationale santé autonomie
dédié à ça donc séparé de la de la
caisse d'assurance maladie et mais qui
était simplement un transfert de fonds à
20 24 25 milliards tous les ans
transféré de l'assurance maladie des
recettes de l'assurance maladie vers
cette caisse et puis on sait déjà
c'était déjà un débat du temps de
monsieur sarkozy dans les années fin des
années 2000 où se dit il faut il faut
qu'on
qu'on isole 7 risque là encore une fois
de façon de mon point de vue est assez
incompréhensible et donc il faut qu'on
crée cette 5ème branche c'était assez
consensuel dans tous les partis
d'ailleurs dans tous les partis mais ça
a été ça pas dans tout ça a été plutôt à
droite mais bref ça a était pas si
consensuel que ça mais ça n'a pas été
non plus c'est pas révoltant le problème
c'est qu'encore une fois à force de
segmenter tous ces risques en matière de
sécurité sociale ont fait que
complexifier alors qu'on sait que
globalement il faut avoir une approche
la plus globale possible du risque est
un risque santé donc aujourd'hui on a
une on a une cinquième branche qui
représente à peu près 26 milliards il
faut savoir que la branche santé
représente près de 230 milliards donc
vous voyez que c'est quand même pas
grand chose donc à aucun enjeu financier
financier puisqu'il est déjà c'est déjà
financé après ce qui reste qu'il faut il
faut une dizaine de milliards d'ici à
2030 ça c'est un autre sujet de savoir
comment on le finance avait financé par
la crds mais évidemment qu'on est
reparti avec une dette sociale de plus
de 150 milliards 7 crds qui sert à
financer cette affaire a trouvé un autre
mais ça c'est un autre c'est donc de mon
point de vue on a complexifié la gestion
larchitecture de financement de ce
risque inutilement bon c'est fait il
faut vivre avec mais je veux juste
revenir sur un point très important que
vous sur la mixité public privé de notre
modèle modèle de la dépendance comme de
notre modèle de la santé en général la
théorie économique est très clair là
dessus que en fait ce n'est pas le
statut de l'opérateur qui compte mais
c'est sa régulation donc la dérive du
privé ne vient pas du fait y'a pas de
raison que le secteur privé à but
lucratif ne soit pas capable de délivrer
à la fois du profit est à la fois une
qualité de prise en charge optimale et
pas de raison ça se fait dans beaucoup
de temps beaucoup et on l'est et en
matière de santé vous avez des cliniques
et le font très bien mais je reviens au
premier point pour la vue c'est quand
vous avez là une dérive de l'état une
dérive du régulateur évidemment là vous
avez un risque du fait de maximiser les
marges de maximiser alors là à risque
avec une amoralité 13 très poussées et
quand ma main mais un point quand même
là dessus ce sont des choses qui sont
parfaitement connues depuis des années
ce que je veux dire par là c'est qu'on
voit la faiblesse de l'état dans son
incapacité dans le mélange des genres a
pas citer des noms
vous avez quand même des structures qui
représente ce secteur là qu'ils ont été
responsables qui ont eu des
responsabilités d'écrire des rapports
publics 1 sur le nouvel ehpad quelques
mois avant la sortie il n'y a pas un mot
sur ces dérives là qui sont parfaitement
connus du secteur est parfaitement
connue d observer qu'il y avait une
forme d'omerta non il y avait une forme
de deux groupes de pression qui ont une
un pouvoir de daspich à 2 2 dans tout
cas d'empêcher l'état de pouvoir faire
son travail de régulateur est-ce que
c'est terminé je n'en sais rien je n'en
sais rien très honnêtement quel il
qu'elle ait la transparence dans ce
secteur y compris pour les résidents
quel va être moi je j'ai un très gros
doutes en tout cas je vois pas tellement
d'efforts là dessus puisque on garde
exactement le régulateur tel qu'il était
en essayant de lui dire on va te donner
plus de moyens pour contrôler mais non
il faut d'abord une transparence totale
sur ce secteur avant de venir la
transparence et à la lame ou
l'amélioration des conditions de vie des
résidents j'aurais quand même vous posez
la question à vous vous êtes sénatrice
quelle recette il faut affecter à cette
cinquième manche alors ça c'était le
sujet de notre premier rapport avec
bernard bonne sur le reste à charge ce
qu'on appelle le reste à charge combien
ça coûte à une famille d'avoir son aïeul
dans un ehpad et donc comment faire pour
diminuer ce reste à charge qui vous
l'avez dit est très
fluctuant et différents départements des
départements à l'eau moi je suis pour
qu'il y ait une part de solidarité
nationale
comme
moi j'ai voté la cinquième branche de la
sécurité sociale
après il peut y avoir une once forcément
par un impôt un budget à respecter la cg
est une réponse il n'ya pas à la hauteur
des 10 milliards supplémentaires
nécessaires de réponse unique et
univoque mais donc il ya la part de la
cg il ya aussi des cotisations qui
peuvent arriver
on mettait nous autour de 40 45 enfin
commencer à penser à
hassar e
jour comme disaient nos nos parents donc
il ya différentes mesures mais les
mesures ça ne fait pas une loi et nous
ce que l'on voudrait c'est que vraiment
ce gouvernement qui a tous les éléments
parce que notre rapport vient s'ajouter
vous l'avais dit à des dizaines de
rapports déjà existants donc le contexte
il est connu les solutions elles sont
esquissées est donc maintenant c'est une
volonté politique qui doit pouvoir les
donner dans un cadre global de qu'est ce
qu'on veut pour nos anciens et comment
on veut vieillir dans notre société
alors bizarrement on aurait pu imaginer
que ce sujet devienne un thème de la
campagne présidentielle ou un thème de
la campagne des législatives et ça n'a
pas été le cas pourquoi parce que c'est
à vous
comme ça vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure on est quand même sur une
personne sur dix qui est âgé de 75 ans
et plus à l'heure actuelle en france on
va passer à une personne sur huit en
2030 donc on est à peu près tous
concernés sauf ceux qui par malheur pas
retirée avant et pourtant c'est comme un
véritable sujet tabou c'est à dire qu'on
n'a pas envie de savoir ce qui se passe
dans les ehpad vous avez parlé de
transparence tout à l'heure rentré peu
dans les ehpad sauf si on a évidemment
de la famille on voit pas ce qui s'y
passe on sait pas qui a une vie dans les
ehpad qu'on peut s'amuser jouer vivre
normalement même tombé amoureux oui on
peut tomber amoureux dans les ehpad et
le fait d'être sur un tabou qui est même
c'est plus que politique parce que là
vous avez parlé de la campagne mais
c'est sociologique voire anthropologique
on veut pas parler des personnes âgées
on veut pas parler même de la mort de la
maladie c'est des choses qui nous
concernent pas ça revient même à
l'hôpital qui va manifester pour
l'hôpital oui en tant de kovy dont va
applaudir mais après on va jamais
manifesté tant qu'on est pas mal hein
tant qu'on n'a pas des problèmes de
santé on veut pas c'est exactement
pareil pour les ehpad et c'est un
problème de fond parce que qui dit abu
dis on va pas voir plus en détail ni sur
le financement et vous en avez largement
parlé ni sur les gouvernances secteur
public secteur privé comment on fait ça
et et ni même comment on peut innover
parce que oui on peut innover ya des
expérimentations ne serait ce que sur
des habitats inclusive c'est à dire
qu'on mélange un petit peu les gens et
gens qui ont besoin qui sont fortement
dépendants des gens qui sont un peu plus
en forme mais que peuvent pas vivre chez
eux et on met des financements qui vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure des conseils
départementaux qui vont aux conseils
départementaux pour avoir même un
animateur qui vient qui offre des
services en plus payant mais qui sont
proposés des repas des soins des
toilettes on a comme ça toute une partie
d'innovation d'autres pays le font mais
c'est vrai que comme on est dans un
tabou et comme on essaie de s'arranger
au mieux et comme on ne fait pas de loi
et qu'on attend toujours cette loi cette
loi cette loi c'est presque comme la
transition écologique un emprunt ça
devient une dépense ça peut être un
investissement
c'est nous plus tard c'est l'avis des
vis et comment en entreprise aussi les
seniors qui sont pas très demandés à 50
ans on n'en veut plus donc il ya tout ce
chamboulement sociologique ou
anthropologique à faire pour miser
dessus et trouver enfin les financements
et une loi qui puisse laisser des jours
heureux à nos vieux qui vieillissent de
plus en plus tardivement et tant mieux
alors on rappelle que cette loi à
laquelle vous faites allusion c'est la
fameuse loi dite grand âge c'était une
promesse d' emmanuel macron et puis
finalement il ne l'a pas fait dès que la
crise qu vide a repoussé à l'agenda
gouvernemental l'occasion de faire cette
loi mais en tout cas elle n'a pas ça n'a
pas été une priorité affichée à la fin
du premier quinquennat de macron
je vais poser une question basique
qu'est-ce qu'il faut parce que c'est
très large c'est toi grand âge mais
qu'est ce qu'il faut dans cet avantage
pour vous mais rigolo alors je vais vous
dire ce qu'il faut mais avant je
voudrais juste revenir sur les propos
qu'a tenus madame je pense que là c'est
essentiel c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui en tout cas l'analyse que
nous faisons à l'ad-pa que nous avons
produit dans une dans une plate forme
politique au moment des élections
présidentielles c'est que le fond de
tous ces l'âgisme c'est la
discrimination par l'âge ça ça a été
déclarée par l'union européenne il y à
beaucoup de pays qui travaillent sur le
sujet malheureusement en france c'est un
non dit nous discriminent nous
discriminons les plus âgés à partir de
50 ans dans le monde du travail et puis
après plus l'avancé se fait grande en
âge et plus les personnes sont
discriminés jusqu'à ce qu'elle atteigne
d âge très avancé et elles sont encore
plus discriminée nous considérons
finalement la france considère que les
personnes âgées qui vivent dans ces
établissements sont des personnes
malades que l'on doit aider et que l'on
doit absolument sûre sécurisée et c'est
là qu'a été créé le modèle ehpad qui ne
convient aucune personne voir implanter
absolument voir infantilisés et
finalement ce qu'il faut donc faire
c'est revoir complètement le modèle la
logique domiciliaire telle qu'envisagée
de pouvoir rester dans ces danses au
logement individuel c'est intéressant
mais la cns a aussi travaillé là-dessus
avec l'ensemble des acteurs c'est
comment je crée un domicile dans les
murs dans ces établissements et nous
pensons que la première des choses c'est
d'arrêter toutes ses normes que qui sont
insupportables
toutes les normes qui sont rsa ni tard
au centre et donc personne ne veut vivre
dans un petit hôpital pendant trois à
cinq six ans dans sa vie personne
d'entre nous ne souhaite pour son avenir
donc il est insupportable aujourd'hui et
donc il faut travailler sur cette loi
parce que nous attendons depuis très
longtemps travaillé sur les droits des
personnes comment elles peuvent comment
elles peuvent avoir être sur le droit
commun finalement puisque on crée un
droit spécifique comme si c'était une
population à part alors qu'il joue au
contraire il faut réfléchir à comment on
peut leur accorder l'accès au droit
commun et ça passe en premier lieu par
le sujet du financement que monsieur
évoqué tout à l'heure c'est pas ça doit
pas être vue comme une charge mais comme
un investissement pour la france sur du
long terme c'est des emplois
durables qui sont non délocalisables et
c'est eva et surtout les travailleurs
qui sont qui sont présents sur le
terrain pour nous directeur vous savez
c'est quand même insupportable de se
dire tous les joueurs ont fait le
maximum mais la qualité qu'on met pour
les personnes qu'on accompagne n'est pas
suffisante il le rythme de travail qu'on
impose aux équipes parmi les
professionnels n'est pas suffisant donc
la fois agir par une loi frédéric vézard
même question un peu répandu mais pas
tout à fait répondu qu'est ce qu'il faut
dans cette loi grand âge est ce qu il la
faut qu'est ce qu'il faut de man alors
d'abord il ya un point c'est pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas à parler du
grand âge c'est qu'on a une approche un
peu honteuse de ce grand âge puisque
c'est une question culturelle question
rapport à la religion chrétienne rapport
à là où vieillissement le grand h
imprègne du bien vieillir c'est à dire
que la france a développé le meilleur
système de soins au monde au 20e siècle
la meilleure capacité à gérer le soins
individuels une fois vous êtes malade
mais nous avons jamais développé le
système de santé publique c'est à dire
avec une approche populationnelle et
préventive donc voyez ce que le le
virage que monsieur pas le basculement
du et les stratégies il est dans le
modèle d'accord c'est de la
responsabilité de l'état même si
évidemment il ya une forte
responsabilité individuelle de réduire
les inégalités sociales de santé on est
un des pays d'europe avec le plus haut
niveau d'inégalité sociale c'est facile
à comprendre puisque vous avez un
gradient social à partir du moment où
vous n'avez pas une un soutien et une
assistance des gens pour rester en bonne
santé des gens voyant social fait
regarder les gens 50% des des classes
populaires fument contre 15% de la
classe aisée bon prenez le premier
facteur de risque vous voyez tout le
gradient social donc forcément tout ça
se répercute sur un mal vieillir et
vieillir vieillir en mauvais état avec
tout un gradient social qui se fait donc
il ya un niveau d'injustice sociale dans
le mauvais dans le vieillissement
mauvaise santé qui quand même qui
devrait interpeller on peut dire surtout
la gauche mais tout tout le tout le
champ vous savez il faut avoir affiché
de nouvelles priorités sur la prévention
avec cette approche là en disant il ya
une responsabilité de l'état à
développer des services qui permettent
d'avoir une santé publique optimale ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut que des
désinvestir dans le soin mais le soin on
est bon même si évidemment tout ça s'est
dégradée parce qu'on a eu une horde de
pathologies chroniques qui fait que tout
est en train de se débrider et un point
commun aussi bien la santé car la
dépendance qu'il faut bien voir et
commun au secteur public comme au
secteur et qui est d'ailleurs en lien
avec moi-même culturel c'est que les
métiers sont absolument plus du tout
attractif il est extrêmement compliqué
monsieur est mieux placé que moi mais
bon on parle toujours de pointe de
moyens bien sûr c'est mal rémunéré ce
qui est quand même un sujet mais c'est
surtout s à une image très mauvaise tout
ce sont des métiers qui sont très
difficiles donc il faut un grand plan
formation pas simplement à l'hôpital
mais dans tous ses métiers et des
médecins jusqu aux aides soignantes pour
revaloriser ce métier et pas que
financièrement c'est que c'est comme ça
qu'on va trouver des bras abc je vous
propose d'exploiter juste ce qu'on
disait le ministre de solidarités de
l'autonomie des personnes handicapées
c'était le 5 juillet précédent à propos
de ce manque de bras dans les ehpad la
question de l'attractivité des métiers
du grand âge c'est pas ce pas seulement
une question de salaire c'est pas
question d'une question de deux parcours
professionnel de formation falla toutes
les mesures techniques c'est aussi
quelque chose qui tient au regard que
porte la société sur les personnes âgées
sur le vieillissement et je pense que
collectivement on a un gros travail à
faire au sein de notre société pour
prévenir aussi les ruptures de lien
familial de lien social associé au
vieillissement
parce que oui mais tout se tient enfin
je veux dire c'est pas beau donc il faut
en effet avoir une grande politique de
santé publique qui qui développe
véritablement des services de
l'éducation
de la santé scolaire jusqu'à l'éducation
sur le bien vieillir ou tout ça ne doit
pas être fonctionnarisé que du secteur
public et tout ça mais il faut mettre en
place des politiques et là il ya tout un
long jeu par exemple moi je suis
convaincu quand vous travaillez à ces
questions que le département dont on se
souvent pas trop ce qui fait est un
pilier absolument sans talent parce
qu'il faut à la fois de la proximité et
du social on appelle ça médico social
c'est bien c'est pas purement médical il
faut être il faut connaître les
territoires donc il faut que ça soit un
pilotage et on parle de plateformes
gérontologique c'est à dire qu'il faut
qu'ils aient des plateformes tout près
de l'habitat des gens et donc je pense
que le département si on avait à
clarifier le l'usiné à gaz actuelle le
département devrait être le principal
opérateur public qui vraiment réguler
club près des territoires le l'état via
les ars doivent être le régulateur et
fixe les règles du jeu ils peuvent
évaluer la performance des choses et
puis à mon avis la cns a doit revenir
s'ils né dans le giron national de la
caisse de la caisse dédiée à la
dépendance doit revenir dans le giron de
la caisse d'assurance maladie si on veut
simplifier un peu tout ça alors là on a
parlé des grandes orientations de cette
fois grand âge je voudrais qu'on parle
aussi de l'amélioration des conditions
de vie des résidents dès maintenant et
je voudrais vous proposer de regarder
l'extrait d'un documentaire que nous
diffusons dimanche à 11h30 ehpad les
failles d'un système de flore sauvages
un jour c'était la chemise de nuit
lé 15 mai et nuit un autre jour elle
avait les mêmes amis claveille qui était
justement elle avait 93 ans elles
sentaient pas moins lorsque ma maman
t'as pas eu la douche non ils m'ont pas
donné aujourd'hui n'avait pas le temps
après un jour et me fait c'est ma vie
j'étais aux toilettes les honneurs
d'être appelé les partis voir une autre
chambre elle m'a laissée aux toilettes à
6 comme ça alors qu'elle peut pas
marcher ma mère voulait pas marché mais
laisse aux toilettes je suis traîné par
terre jusqu'au 10 à la maison elle est
jamais un des bleus comme ça jamais mais
le nez cassé aussi une fois le 13
février ma mère me laisse un message en
me disant voilà en pis je suis tombée
dans la nuit j'appelais pour aller aux
toilettes est pas venu je suis tombée
dans la nuit au bout de deux heures il
ya l'aide soignante qui venaient me voir
et me dit madame même a dit madame met
des billes ou me dérangeait chaque fois
ça fait but que vous déranger tout le
temps maintenant vous rester par terre
ouais pas tomber de plus bas
sur l'épouvantable ces témoignages
éprouvant parce que on a l'impression
d'assister à une forme de répétition
sont pas les premiers qu'on entend ils
ont en même temps chacun leur propre
histoire leur propre comme un génie et
il sait manier comment on fait pour
améliorer dès maintenant les conditions
de vie des résidents parce qu'on ya les
grands et les grands projets de loi les
grandes orientations bompard dont on
parlait mais là et à ce qui est des
mesures à prendre de maintenant oui et
notamment ce qui vient d'être dit en
témoignage c'est que ces familles qui
signale
elles ont l'impression qu'elles ne sont
pas entendus et donc c'est aussi ce
qu'on préconise c'est que les alertes
les événements
problématique quand ils sont signalées
doivent être traités bien sûr mais
surtout on doit donner la réponse à ceux
qui ont signalé qu'est ce que c'est
devenu ça parce que la réalité fait
qu'on n'est pas tous les jours voir
toutes les semaines en ehpad voir sa
personne âgée de la famille donc on a
besoin d'avoir un retour sur
les questions qui se posent quand c'est
plus que ça et qu'on sait grave
évidemment qu il faut traiter tout de
suite donc on propose concrètement il ya
un outil qui fonctionne depuis 2002
c'est le conseil de vie sociale dans
tous les établissements aux personnes
âgées il y a donc cette instance qui
normalement regroupent leurs
représentants des familles les résidents
leurs représentants des professionnels
le directeur est normalement un élu de
la commune
alors ça n'a pas empêché parce que bien
au fil du temps d'abord il n'y a pas eu
forcément d'incitation ça relevait
beaucoup de l'aveyron personnel
de la directrice ou directeur et puis là
là c'est pareil pas de de contrôle ou en
tout cas pas de suivi de cette mesure
2002 vous rendez compte et là il ya un
décret donc le gouvernement a pris
rapidement fin avril 2022 pour préciser
la composition le rythme extra est
donnée de la de l'extériorité dans ces
lieux où souvent c'est du confinement
c'est vraiment des choses très dures ou
voilà mais je ne connais pas deux
professionnels qui font ces gestes
maltraitant par choix s'ils le font
c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres
solutions que des très bas par sadisme
est sûr que non non quand une aide
soignante non quand une aide soignante à
12 personnes à s'occuper sur laitages
c'est vrai que la toilette elle est
faite trop vite elle est sûrement pas
fait avec tout le respect parce que le
vieillissement c'est la lenteur vous
rendez compte vieillissement c'est
l'allongement des du temps qu'il faut
pour prendre pour pour se déplacer pour
se vêtir pour manger pas pour tous et le
temps c'est ce qui manque
même question qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
dès maintenant le temps c'est ce qui
manque et donc il faut deux postes
supplémentaires dans tous les
établissements à condition de trouver
des gens pour les occuper je vais vous
dire comment les trouver et dans tous
les services à domicile parce que depuis
le début de l'émission fait une focale
sur les établissements mais il y a tout
autant de personnes âgées aujourd'hui en
france qui sont accompagnés à domicile
la moyenne d'heures d'accompagnement à
domicile c'est une heure par jour donc
23 heures sur 24 la personne est seule
donc faut jamais oublier tout ce pan de
l'accompagnement avec des professionnels
aussi extrêmement fragilisé ce qu'il
faut là ces deux postes dans chaque
établissement dans chaque service à
domicile et pas uniquement des postes de
soignants si on ne trouve pas de postes
de soignants parce que l'état n'a pas
suffisamment formés de personnes pendant
toutes ces années il est dix d'autres
professionnels qui peuvent venir
travailler il ya des psychologues qui
sont sur le marché du travail à des
animateurs qui sont également également
sur le marché du travail et puis à tous
jeunes qui souhaitent se réinsérer
professionnellement qui pourrait venir
accompagné notamment dans des situations
caniculaire qu'on traverse aujourd'hui
c'est quand même assez simple maintenant
faut le financement est annoncée deux
postes supplémentaires dans chaque
établissement et chaque service à
domicile mais nous semble pas démesuré
je rappellerai quand même qu emmanuel
macron s'est soucié de la question du
grand âge suite à la grève que l'ad-pa
et l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales vont organiser en 2018 donc
et il n'y a pas eu de il ya eu de
nombreux rapports de très bons rapports
d'ailleurs mais pour l'instant il n'y a
toujours pas et ça c'est extrêmement mal
vécu par l'ensemble des professionnels
des résidents qu'ils nous le disent et
des familles et les familles en éric
bédard pour conclure qu est-ce qu on
peut changer dès maintenant je lui
rendrai pas l'urgence et la
restructuration complète du modèle je
vous assure que c'est comme parce que
j'aurai toujours ce débat-là de dire oui
mais attendez ça c'est pour plus tard
non parce que à force de reporter ce qui
va permettre de redonner l'espoir aux
gens qui travaillent parce que les gens
sont intelligents savent aujourd'hui les
gens ne croient plus dans ce modèle et
ils ont raison parce que ce modèle est
mort surtout on arrête de construire des
ehpad surtout on arrête de construire
les ehpad qu'on a lancé il ya 25 ans qui
était adapté ya 25 ans qui ne sont plus
adaptées pourquoi parce que dans une
ehpad vous avez un peu de ces fameux j
de 1 à 5 sur des gens qui ont des
niveaux de perte d'autonomie très
différent donc des prises en charges qui
doivent être très différents donc on
mélange tout et il ya des gens qui ont
besoin d'une assistance médicale très
poussé d'autres qui ont besoin de pas
d'assistance médicale mais simplement il
qu'ils n'ont rien à faire dans les ehpad
d'accord donc je vois que ça a été dit
que c'est lié au financement passe quand
on dit mais il faut de ce rapport aux
gémeaux disait faut 9 milliards moi je
suis pas tellement d'accord avec ça
parce que l'on finance quoi il faut
d'abord savoir ce qu'on va financer on
va certainement pas financé à périmètre
équivalent à une hausse du nombre des
bateaux non on va financer la liberté de
choix des personnes de rester chez eux
avec de la domotique ou d'aller dans des
résidences intermédiaires ou à des
résidences collectif un bref on connaît
tout ça et là vous pouvez avoir une
diversité des financements d'ailleurs je
suis d'accord avec moi-même deux
sénatrices que moi je suis pour
évidemment un financement qu'il soit
socialiser pour des raisons de justice
sociale mais ce qui n'empêche que quand
vous diversifier les structures vous
pouvez avoir d'autres sources de
financement de collectivités
territoriales mais aussi des
financements privés donc oui tout ça
c'est pas très compliqué on sait comment
le faire mais l'urgence c'est la
refondation du modèle merci ce sera le
mot de la fin c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à vous d'y avoir
participé merci à vous derrière votre
écran de l'avoir regardé je vous
retrouve demain pour un nouveau numéro
100 publique mnb à jeudi
[Musique]